مهما قتلوا مهما دمروا
مهما سفكوا دماء مهما ارتكبوا من مجازر
فشعبنا صامد على ارضه بلدي ها وطني هذا
عرضي ارضي وعرضي ها
فلسطينين خس الاحتلال و لعالم ان يجبرنا
نطلع من هنا هذه ارضي هذا وطني بدهم
يهجرنا جباري ما بدنا نطلع عادي موتونا
مكاننا بس ب نسيب ارضنا حياتنا عيشتنا ه
كلنا ما بنسيبها
نهائي سته ملايين لاجئ فلسطيني في قلب كل
واحد منهم قصه حكايات وان اختلفت في
تفاصيل تجتمع على حق العوده لفلسطين اللي
امه ضايعه صار لها 70 سنه بدور عليها بس
بفكر انه يشوفها
ويحضنها
ويضمها يا اخي في واحد ببدل امه يا اخي ل
بلا اعطيك واحده غير امك هي امي لو انه
جواز احمر سياسي ما ب بدله بتراب فلسطين
ما الذي تقولينه لاحفاد حتى تبقي موضوع حق
العوده لفلسطين حي
في وجدانهم باستمرار انا دائما بحكي
احفادي احنا لازم دائما نفكر في العوده
باي طريقه لازم نفكر
بالعوده فلسطين هي بلدنا بلدي انا بلد
اجدادي بلد احفادي عننا بكل بيت في خريطه
فلسطين بكل بيت في مفتاح العوده معلق
العلم فلسطيني معلق عنا بالبيوت كل البيوت
اولادي واحفادي وكلياتنا متعلقين بفلسطين
في ظل معطيات ال
والارتباط بين الرؤيه الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه للحل كيف ترى مستقبل القضيه
الفلسطينيه وحق العوده حق العوده هو غير
قابل للتصرف من اي شخص ولا اي مؤسسه ولا
اي زعيم ولا اي امير ولا اي
[موسيقى]
شيخ